la tasa a la que cae el agua de lluvia
por una tubería de desagüe está modelada
por la siguiente función r dónde r dt es
igual a 20 veces el seno de t cuadrada
entre 35 pies cúbicos entre horas que
está medido en horas y 0 es menor o
igual que te menor igual que 8 entonces
te está entre 0 y 8 la tubería de
desagüe está parcialmente bloqueada
permitiendo que el agua se drene al otro
extremo de la tubería con una taza
modelada por la función de dtm es igual
y tenemos esta función menos 0.04 t
pública más 0.4 de cuadrada más 0.96
este pie cúbico entre ahora para
en el mismo intervalo si es igual a 0
hay 30 pies cúbicos de agua en la
tubería de desagüe entonces el inciso am
nos preguntan cuántos pies cúbicos de
agua de lluvia fluyen a través de la
tubería durante las ocho horas es decir
durante el intervalo de tiempo cero
menor o igual que t menor o igual que
ocho entonces veamos qué te parece si
dibujamos primero un poco la tubería
para que sea más visible todo este
problema así que por aquí voy a dibujar
a mi tubería supongamos que es esta de
aquí tengo por aquí a mi tubería y bueno
esta tubería tiene una tasa de entrada
de bueno aquí lo dice la tasa de entrada
es r dt así que esta tubería fluye una
cierta cantidad de agua con una tasa de
e
de té
y bueno por otra parte también nos dice
que el agua fluye hacia afuera de ella
con una taza de té entonces también el
agua fluye hacia fuera con una taza de
té bien y también nos dicen que cuando
el tiempo es igual a cero hay treinta
pies cúbicos de agua en la tubería de
desagüe este es el dato de lo que pasa
justo en el principio y bueno aquí ya
tenemos la tasa de entrada la tasa de
salida y entonces nos preguntan cuántos
pies cúbicos de agua de lluvia fluyen a
través de la tubería durante las ocho
horas
bueno si tenemos la tasa la tasa a la
que fluye el agua hacia dentro de la
tubería y nos la dan en pies cúbicos
sobre hora entonces a esta tasa que es r
dt a esta tasa que es r dt vamos a
multiplicar la por pequeños muy pequeños
cambios en el tiempo por cambios
infinitesimalmente pequeños de tiempo es
decir por de de tema
entonces esto nos da la cantidad de agua
que fluye hacia dentro en un pequeño
cambio en el tiempo entonces lo que
vamos a querer hacer es sumar todas
estas cantidades a lo largo de cambios
muy pequeños en el tiempo desde el
tiempo te iguala 0 hasta el tiempo te
igual a 8 así que esta expresión que
tengo aquí es la que nos va a dar la
cantidad de agua de lluvia que fluyen a
través de la tubería
que es justo lo que estamos buscando y
una vez más lo que estoy diciendo aquí
es bueno primero observar que el dt
dt es la cantidad de agua que fluye
hacia dentro de la tubería en un
intervalo muy pequeño de tiempo dt y
después nos vamos a tomar la suma de
todos ellos desde el tiempo de igual a
cero hasta el tiempo de igual a 8 esta
es la definición de una integral
definida entonces esto tiene que ser
igual a bueno a la integral de 0 a 8 drt
pero el dt es esto de aquí 20 veces el
seno de la función bueno te cuadrada de
cuadrada entre 35 y esto x de t y ahora
para nuestra suerte podemos usar la
calculadora en esta parte de la sección
del examen de ap
así que voy a traer por acá mi
calculadora que me va a ayudar a
resolver esta integral definida y bueno
para resolverla los pasos son los
siguientes primero vamos a seleccionar
esta parte donde dice más aquí lo
tenemos y nos vamos a ir al número 9 al
número 9 que dice fn integral lo que
quiere decir integral definida sobre una
función así que vamos a presionar esta
opción y ahora la forma en la que se
meten los datos es la siguiente primero
pones los datos de tu función es decir
de esta función que tengo aquí después
la variable a la que queremos integrar
la variable bajo la cual tomaremos la
integral y por último tomaremos los
límites de la integral
entonces esto nos quedarían 20 que
multiplica al seno de iu bueno por aquí
está la t entonces dt elevado
cuadrado esto dividido a su vez entre 35
ok ahora cerramos los paréntesis de la
expresión a la cual le vamos a aplicar
el seno y después hay que poner una coma
la variable bajo la cual tomaremos la
integral la cual esté muy bien y después
de que poner una coma y los límites de
integración en este caso los límites de
integración es 0 y es 8 y después
cerramos paréntesis ojo aquí tenemos el
límite inferior y aquí tenemos el límite
superior y ahora sí se presionamos enter
ya lo tenemos llegamos a 76 punto 57 0
entonces esto es aproximadamente déjame
ponerlo aproximadamente 76
punto 57
bien esta es la respuesta del inciso a
de este problema muy bien así que ahora
vamos al inciso b que es justo este que
tenemos aquí la cantidad de agua en la
tubería está creciendo o decreciendo en
el tiempo te iguala 3 justifica tu
respuesta bien ahora queremos saber qué
es lo que pasa en el tiempo te iguala 3
y bueno qué tiene que pasar para que la
cantidad de agua crezca bueno si la tasa
a la que entra es mayor a la tasa a la
que sale entonces la cantidad de agua
estaría creciendo en la tubería estás de
acuerdo esto en el tiempo de igual a 3
ahora en otro caso si la cantidad de
agua que sale es mayor a la cantidad de
agua que entra entonces la cantidad de
agua estaría decreciendo así que vamos a
escribirlo lo voy a poner así
efe y bueno voy a poner tres porque me
estoy fijando en el tiempo de igual a
tres si era de tres la cantidad de agua
a la que entra en el tiempo te iguala
tres es mayor que la cantidad de agua a
la que sale en el tiempo de igual a tres
entonces qué pasa
bueno eso significa que la cantidad de
agua estaría creciendo así que luego
escribe aquí entonces la
cantidad
de agua
crece bien ahora que pase en el otro
caso si de de tres es decir la cantidad
de agua a la que sale en el tiempo de
igual a tres es mayor que la cantidad de
agua que entra en el tiempo de igual a
tres bueno entonces la cantidad de agua
va a decrecer entonces
cantidad
de agua
decrece
así que qué te parece si evaluamos estas
dos funciones en el tiempo te igual a
tres para poder compararlas así que
veamos si por aquí me fijo en el valor
de rd 3 quiere ser de 3 bueno pues si
recordamos la función r es lo mismo que
20 veces el seno de t cuadrada en este
caso es 3 elevado al cuadrado entre 35
bien pues cuánto es esto
ahora para eso voy a sacar de nuevo mi
calculadora por aquí la tengo por acá y
vamos a hacer justo esta operación que
tengo aquí quiero calcular 20
el seno de bueno 3 al cuadrado 2 99
entre 35 y estoy suponiendo que mi
calculadora está en radiales y esto me
da 5.09 aproximadamente así que lo voy a
notar esto es aproximadamente
aproximadamente 5.09 y recuerda esto
está dado en pies cúbicos
ahora vamos a calcular de de 3 y para
eso
déjame recordar cuánto valía la función
de vamos a subir un poco en la pantalla
y aquí está la función de es esta que
tengo aquí y esta vez la voy a poner
justo por acá para que podamos ver la
función y voy a poner menos 0.04 0.04
que multiplica a 3 al cubo esos 27 y a
esto hay que sumarle 0.4 que multiplica
a 3 al cuadrado lo cual es 9 y a esto
habrá que sumarle 0.96 que multiplica a
3 y eso me va a dar 5.4 así que está de
lujo lo voy a notar aquí si bajamos de
nuevo nuestra pantalla
voy a poner que desde 3 es igual a 5.4
y ahora puedes ver que de de 3 es más
grande que el de 3 lo que quiere decir
que sale más agua de la que entra
entonces entonces la cantidad de agua
cantidad de agua
va a decrecer de creer
el agua se drena más rápido de lo que
entra